daniel hall uh sure who the [ __ ] is what
the [ __ ] was that did anyone hear that
jay says okay okay [ __ ] someone's
like screaming toilet I shooting off
missiles and [ __ ] jaysus uh I like
chicken I'd oh I really like chicken oh
ok ok
see we chickens aren't that tough you'd
think they'd be like tucks are huge but
it's just simply not true which is
simply not true combat you come on come
on mm-hmm quick saving match quick
setting yeah banging back baby baby yeah
someone is raging someone's raging you
gotta go high up yeah that's this house
thing
okay okay
okay okay good don't worry I got your
neck can I go higher up oh it's clearly
[ __ ] out you know let's see what to that
grasshopper note yeah I have a house
doubt babe I let's do it baby I'm sorry
that you can save those anyways nearby
I'm a little nightmare baby couldn't
change this okay come on come on little
bit colada before me baby come on yeah
Mary um hello hello I'm trying to play
this haha hello hello Jesus
mari both fish we shot that is gues mati
never quite made food for grass over at
it look up for examine Oh read it who
the [ __ ] is shooting okay okay ooh okay
I got to read this [ __ ] mm-hmm okay
called food for grasshopper think it is
on the banks of the Charles okay
no nice challenge let's [ __ ] ass
stretch oh hey if I wouldn't faster to
walk there cuz the [ __ ] loading
screen takes like 10 years mmm some eye
drops and I guess okay I got one I down
okay choice down I can't work out for
good oh I'm close so close all right fit
those quick same button and let's do
this oh baby baby baby baby baby baby
baby where's the guy where's the guy oh
[ __ ] any [ __ ] goals in here deck deck
deck
oh there's the cert Wow Adam so buried
with all this treasure wow that was good
anyway thank you sir
you